leider bedeutet april april
allerdings soll es heute nicht um
irgendwelche originellen veralteten
aprilscherze geben sondern wirklich um
kreative ideen wie man seine mitmenschen
reinlegen kann
und da würde ich sagen starten wir
direkt mit diesem prank und zwar hat
dort jemand einfach extrem viele
luftballons und eine folie gepackt und
diese folie festgeklebt hinter einer tür
die ein wenig glas hat und von der
anderen seite sieht das ganze dann so
ich glaube da wird keiner rein geben
wollen die nächste aprilscherz hat eine
person an einem arbeitskollegen
durchgeführt und zwar dass hier
falls ihr euch fragt was das ist das ist
eine tastatur und er hat die rede den
einzelnen buchstaben jede einzelne zahl
also jede einzelne taste hat er
abgenommen hat dort diese weise was auch
immer das ist hin gepackt also im kleber
erscheint dann das braune zeigt ist
anscheinend irgendein dünger oder so und
da wächst jetzt christ aus aus der
tastatur von seinem mitarbeiter als ja
entspannt stell dir vor dem chef sagen
wo bleiben die dateien nur sagte sorry
da wächst irgendwas aus meiner tastatur
aus dass jetzt der nächste aprilscherz
der tatsächlich in deutschland so
stattgefunden hat und zwar braucht man
da glaube ich gar nicht viel zu sagen
jemand hat ein auto entdeckt und hat
dort einfach ringsherum einkaufswägen
drum gespannt ich frage mich allerdings
irgendwo
muss das ganze doch also
um allerdings wieder zurück ins büro
beziehungsweise zurück an den
arbeitsplatz bekommen eine person hat
das hier unter den maus sensor seiner
kollegin geklebt und zwar bewegt sie
dann ihre maus und die maus bewegt sich
auf dem screen halt nicht und wenn sie
sie um dreht sie halt dieses roll fans
lachen was auch ziemlich frech ist ist
das hier ein erhorn unter den stuhl der
erinnert sich darauf seine fliegende die
ohren weg das hier ist der nächste
aprilscherz und zwar geht es dabei um
zwiebeln die zwiebeln werden komplett
geschält und dann brauchst du eben auch
zwiebeln die ja in etwa so groß sind wie
so äpfel sage ich mal und dann werden
die rotarier seht schon das sollen
zucker glasierte äpfel seien oder wie
auch immer die heißen und ich glaube
wenn die zwiebel rhein weist boa der
wird ein paar tage ordentlich gammeln
dass jetzt der nächste start und auf den
ersten blick erkennt man hier glaube ich
gar keinen großen unterschied zu einem
normalen auto wenn man allerdings
genauer hinschaut sieht man dass sich
dort eine person in den sitzreihen
gesetzt hat sie hat sich quasi zu einem
sitz verwandelt und wenn man an diesem
auto vorbei fährt denkt man sich
das ist ja gar keiner drin ich bin gut
2010 wir sind nie so laut
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dieser nächstebreck hier ist so
unfassbar fies und zwar hat dort eine
person mentors in einer eis würfelform
gepackt und wenn eine person sich jetzt
beispielsweise eine cola macht witze er
seine cola haben will und man selbst
gibt der person die cola packt man
einfach so ein paar eiswürfel hin da
rein und irgendwann in die eiswürfel
aufgelöst sind reagiert das mentos mit
der cola unter ding fliegt die um die
ohren das hier ist ein spray also ein
köder und zwar das sind schwimmt
geschmack also das kann man
beispielsweise dann ins meer springen
und dann kommen da halt größere fische
an weil sie denken dass sind schrems er
hat dort allerdings dass hier darum
gepackt ein raum erfrischung spray
stelle
du kommst in ein büro in der firma und
denkst dir so riecht ein bisschen früher
einfach kurz ein bisschen raum er
frischer sein und es riecht einfach nur
nach fisch das ist auf jeden fall frech
was auch frech ist ist das hier
da hat jemand eine kleine spielzeug
schlange zwischen salatköpfe in den
supermarkt gelegt
ich werde erst mit einem herzinfarkt
rausgerannt wäre wo ich allerdings nicht
gerannt wäre meine lieben freunde meine
güte ist wieder ein übergangs meister am
werk
ich will auf jeden fall nicht gerade bei
dieser situation das sind alles einzelne
kleine plastikbecher bis zum rand voll
aufgefüllt mit wasser wer hat so viel
langeweile dass dort aufzustellen und
wer muss das nachher wieder wegmachen am
nächsten der frisch jetzt geht's auch um
wasser und zwar es ist dieser hier wird
schon den zettel have fun kliniken love
you ready und ja ich weiß wie wir haben
dies denn dahin bekommen in dem glas
wasser einfach genommen was drauf
umgedreht der aufgeschobenen weggezogen
nur schritt genau so kann man es ja dann
auch wieder
wir kriegen einfach gras neben oder sehe
ich das falsch
das hier ist der nächste aprilscherz
erst wieder extrem böse und handelt auch
wieder von einem kleinen mentors und
zwar ist durch den mentor strom
beziehungsweise an den menschen dran ist
ein kleiner faden und diesen faden macht
die person hier dran also an den
flaschenhals einer dose beispielsweise
cola und dann in den deckel das mentors
rein
er spannt den faden und schneidet den
faden dann an beiden enden ab so dass
man ihn nicht sieht
und wenn dann eine person die flasche
auf macht denkt er sicherheits a super
coole flasche mache ich mal auf und in
dem moment fällt das mentors rein und
bumm
alles ist voll mit coca cola dann in dem
raum und wie frech ist das einfach ist
das aber noch viel frecher ist das ist
nämlich das hier und zwar ist das hier
dieser kleine dusche apparat den muss
man manchmal ab machen wenn man den
irgendwie entkalken will oder so und
daran hat die person einfach klasse
getan
eine eine einer hühnerbrühe das heißt
wenn jemand duscht
durch frühe sommer wie ekelhaft ist dass
das jetzt der nächste aprilscherz der
extrem aufwändig ist beziehungsweise war
allerdings auch sehr kreativ ist und
zwar dort eine person den arbeitsplatz
seines kollegen zu einem kleinen garten
entwickelt sogar mit zum flamingo da
drin zum paar steinchen so von wegen hey
das ist ein
das ist ein wenig zu deinem pc auch mit
seinem schild hier im kiez auf gras oder
so kleine bäche 30 fast daraus wächst
vielleicht pflanzen oder kakteen sollen
dann noch rein oder so wird sogar ein
kleines wasser teil dahin gepackt frage
mich einfach indem unternehmen konzern
wirtschaftlich nicht so gut laufen wenn
die zeit für sowas haben allerdings ist
das hier der nächste aprilscherz und man
fragt sich jetzt im ersten moment
vielleicht hängt das ist dass das ist
ein stück pappe und die person packt das
stück pappe ich hier rein marinade wort
er war packt das dann noch mal hier rein
also ein bisschen inso brösel und dass
seine fahne und es sieht aus wie sonnen
putenschnitzel besser machen allerdings
direkt mit diesem aprilscherze weiter
und zwar ist das hier keine person die
dort irgendwie auf dem boden liegt
sondern das ist einfach eine
ausgestopfte hose mit irgendwie wäsche
mit irgendwie alten gebrauchten t shirts
dann auch eine ausgestopfte jacke die
allerdings darunter ein pullover
handschuhe hat die person in der hand
und sogar schuhe liegen dort oben an den
beiden enden der person ja wenn ich da
in das badezimmer reingehen würde und
das wäre bei einem kollegen ich würde
aus dem fenster springen das ist der
nächste break und zwar eine person diese
bunten mal minen whatever unter dem
scheibenwischer beziehungsweise in den
scheibenwischer verlauf des gelegt und
als person losgefahren ist und den
scheibenwischer benutzt hat sei das
ganze so aus
ja ich meine du siehst auf jeden fall
die ganze seiten regenbogen ist ein
schöner ausblick das ist jetzt der
nächste streich und zwar ist das wieder
ein raum erfrischung allerdings hat die
person oben dran so eine art ich weiß
nicht genau wie das heißt man kann das
so zu ziehen und das zuerst kriegt man
das nur noch auf wenn man das
durchschneidet auf jeden fall hat die
person derzeit daran gemacht hat es ein
bisschen offen gelassen und damit könnte
man jetzt beispielsweise wenn ihr
geschwister habt oder so einfach an das
zimmer gehen anklopfen die person sagt
ja komm rein und dann kommt man rein
die das zu und schweiß ist einfach rein
und dann ist das einfach da drin und
sprüht die ganze zeit um sich und ich
meine ich denke mir einfach ok klar mit
dem rauriser ist schon blöd wenn man
davon die sehr viel benutzt das riecht
schon echt unangenehm dann aber wenn man
shrimps spray benutzt damit wäre das
vielleicht auch noch mal ganz lustig das
hier ist der nächste aprilscherz passt
auch gut zur aktuellen situation mit dem
ganzen klopapier allerdings soll auch
schon zum vorletzten aprilscherz fürs
heutige video und zwar wurde er in eine
facebook-gruppe gepostet meine letzte
ist es aufhört nissan pringles fortan
das team im play off broadway
falls das gegen jemanden nicht ganz
verstanden hat sie hat jede einzelne
pringles chip wache in der verpackung
angelegt den flavour abgelegt und damit
rein getan und die dann der schwester
gegeben
das ist ekelhaft was auch ekelhaft es
ist das hier das ist der letzte
aprilscherz das heutige video ich glaube
dann hatten wir auch schon sowie 12
andere auch im letzten video was ich
letztes jahr zu den lustigsten
aprilscherze 2009/10 gemacht habe dass
hier seht ihr schon die richtigen member
der lubu kennen das auch schon das sind
so kleine ausgeschnittener kakerlaken
und wenn man die dann beispielsweise
eine lampe rein klebt extrem unangenehm
wenn ich das sehen würde ich würde
direkt die ich direkt mein eigenes grab
schaufeln an der stelle ich das heute
wieder beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat das gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier darin
schreibt mir aber ohnehin die kommentare
ob ihr heute schon schwester bruder mama
papa gedrängt hat oder ob ihr selber
heute reingelegt wurden am ersten april
hier findet ihr ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf klickt seit die abonnent
von meinem canalis ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr so mega cool
und hier findet ihr ein anderes video
verlinkt irgendein video könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken weil wir haben
gerade alle nicht zu tun
hat irgendwie nicht